you're on a testosterone-fueled set with
these guys did you feel like you fit in
pretty well yeah they're a bunch of
divas yeah you guys know it's like to
work with men my hair okay he's my
makeup you've talked about this before
that men sometimes are more concerned
than than women usually whenever I work
I feel like in every project I work on
there's usually like a few of the guys
that are just takes so much time in
between takes like wait check my hair
check they want to look in the mirror
all the time it's like you look the same
move on yeah but yeah the guys are
usually the tougher I think they take up
more time on set and their glam stuff
but this this particular group of guys
is so interesting because we all just
would hang out in between you know set
up the stuff now normally people go back
to their trailer but we just all loved
hanging out talking and talked about
quantum physics and Thomas Jane has so
many amazing story he's an interesting
stuff and Keegan as well has the
funniest stuff so we all just hang out
and talk like you know quantum physics I
was reading some Carl young books and
passing those around so is actually does
this get really sad or lame I'm talking
inflation utter satyr lamb I just don't
think people believe it
it's invite by Carl Jung and then Us
Weekly
you